I knew it was coming and I would have
said that either way you know before and
after but it's such a good time DJ that
we actually spent the entire flight home
next to each other by me rapid dancing
me actually we're talking to each other
after all of that Wow
you there Daniel but a rich I thought
when I got home I was going to open up
the doors and you were just gonna be
sitting like who are people not in my
kitchen right to use the cheers
reference no see another thing it's just
it's kind of refreshing that you would
get pop-culture references after stripes
because that was the way that I was be
dealing with mike Mayock for 15 years
you know but did you notice when when I
don't brockman notice but when Mike came
into the booth rich has like a switch it
just like automatically flipped and then
he started like dialing the references
back more into like yes even at the 70
and Mike was picking them up it just
rich has that ability to switch gears do
you know what unfuck unless it's my run
but we'll get to that in in short order
the story of the combine is what in your
estimation well I mean it's crazy
because he just he didn't do anything on
the field but Kyler Murray was still the
buzz I mean you know always asked what
the story the combine is to me it's what
people are talking about in the evenings
when we leave the stadium and that was
the that was the dominant conversation
you know what he was always 510 which we
considered total after a five nine
expectation he was 207 pounds which was
bigger than expected and then you know
the conversation shifts to what are the
Arizona Cardinals going to do are they
going to take him are they going to
trade rosin or is this all chant smoke
screen I mean that was that was the
dominant conversation the entire time
down there and what's your sense I
started by saying there's no chance that
the Cardinals have already made their
decision
zero so what's your take on that there's
so much and it's it's nothing's
consistent so you know I I'm leaning
towards the Cuyler Murray thing I'm
leaning towards that happening so that's
just you know I would say if you're
gonna put it on a scale I would say 70
to 75% of the people I talk to
in all different realms in the football
or in the football world have believed
it so I'm gonna trust them on that and
that their gut instinct there so I do
think there's a really good chance Tyler
Mary's gonna be the first pick what
would you do
DJ you're the general manager let's put
you in Steve calm shoes what would you
do knowing that the owner just
one-and-done the coach you know and
knowing that you've got a new head coach
that nobody really saw coming so what
would you do knowing that there is a
possibility of calamari but that would
require you'd have to trade rosin
you'd have to trade him you don't know
when you have to trade him would you
trade him after drafted I mean what
would you do or just stay Pat knowing
rose in the evaluation about the next
step in the National Football League ear
yeah I mean personally I have a higher
grade on Josh than I did on Tyler and
they're totally different players so if
it was me I would I would continue to
try and help you know especially looking
up along the offensive line and create
this is being aggressive being able to
to get that defense cranked up again
you've got a chance at my opinion get
the best players in the draft and post
up that's where I would go now there's a
difference in what I would do and then
also understanding they have a if this
is their plan you know if you hire Kliff
Kingsbury and you are going to go all in
around his offense and around his system
in and go for it then I understand the
Cuyler Murray thing in that in that
situation because of the the
relationship between those guys how he
would fit into what they want to do in
the mere fact that as bad as they are
the offensive line in the short term
Tyler Murray will be able to get away
from some of that the Josh would be able
to get away from but I think you get in
trouble when you can kind of make these
short-term decisions I think Josh Rosen
has a chance to term quality and
personally I would do my best to try and
build up around him okay now let's just
say Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich
Eisen show what would you give up for
Rosen if you're another team out there
and you think that he is available and
that or you are buying the if you will
smoke screen if that's what it is
from Arizona and you go knock on the
door and all you know what's the
Godfather offer do you think if you're
if you're the general manager looking
for rosin well I mean I know some things
were out there saying they would not be
able to get a first I'll pick that was
to me if they could not get a first
round pick to fall on people at 13 and I
mean he's gonna be better than anything
you're gonna see at 13 in my opinion if
I'm 15 in Washington he's gonna be
better than anything you're gonna see
there at 15 and if for some reason they
can't get any of those teams to bite I
would I would sure think the Patriots
down at 32 I mean that's uh that would
be a that would be a very short
discussion for me yes I would do it
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show with the hottest rumor coming out
of the combine that the two of us sat
next to each other all weekend long on
the NFL Network bringing home to you
okay so power on the table for Nick Bosa
to Arizona what would that look like for
that team well I mean I just I think you
look at the best teams in the league
there's good upfront offensively they
can rush the quarterback and they get a
great quarterback play so to me when a
quarterback he's just the old as any
restaurateurs to come out and a long
time and he's not as dynamic as you know
the barrio Williams the Julius Peppers
the clown he's the Garrett's he's not as
just a physical to freak like those guys
but he killed of a pass rusher with his
hands he can take over a football game
you know people look at the 40 time it
was a four seven nine but his 10 split
was tied for the third best private
group and that's what you're looking for
in those defensive linemen so I've got
somebody that's got a quick get off he's
got great hands he looks like he's fully
healthy after he suffered during the
season and it doesn't hurt what when you
look at what Zoe was done so to me
that's a pretty darn good football
player throw in the mix and throw 34
let's go intubation where you got to go
after Jared Goff and in Garoppolo and
Russell Wilson that would that be a nice
that'd be nice front to build around
let's talk DK Metcalf a little bit here
Daniel only sixty seven catches we know
he had an injury a neck injury is
serious injury from which he clearly
came back
to blow out the combine and one of the
more moving moments was our NFL Network
cameras capturing him crying facetiming
with a family member we believe so
what's the evaluation on him as he
closer to Julio Jones or Mike Mamula did
you get my that's quite the scale I know
whether you Kyurem calico know I mean
what's what I mean look he clearly
rocked up he called him the human Batman
suit he was incredible yeah you know the
measurable that everyone was talking
about outside of Kyle Murray's height
was the body fat measurement of decay
Metcalf what do you think well I mean
first of all you think what people look
at combine workout warriors the way I
look at that is okay what was the
evaluation before you got in
Indianapolis and in my top 50 list DK
Metcalf believe was number 16 coming in
to the combine so this is not somebody
that we had as a fourth pick
he ran really fast everybody's
overreacting and saying he's gonna be a
first-round guy he was he was already in
that first round that's now he's not
he's not a perfect player you know Julio
Joe has more production was more
polished coming out but he is big
physical and fast and he does have some
big plays on tape there's just a ton of
production because of the injuries so
that's what you factor in I think the
ability is there you know what you're
buying a vertical threat you're getting
somebody you can use down in the red
zone now he was polished running
comebacks and curls and explode out of
breaks like that's not what you're
getting so to me it comes down to which
team does he go to and how do they plan
to use him and I spoiler alert' rich
I've already done a new mock draft this
morning okay I gotta be coming out soon
but I'm just I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
give you the whole mock crap but I'm
gonna give you this one we're on the
topic here
DK Metcalf when I look at what the
Buffalo Bills could use and where they
ticket number nine and you look at Josh
Allen who can throw the ball over the
moon and now you've got a big explosive
receiver like that they can get on top
of coverage and then you look at Josh
Allen who maybe it's not the most
point accurate you have a frame like BK
Metcalf has he's just a perfect fit in
that offense to grow with John Allen all
right nice little Christmas gift early
underneath a Buffalo Bills tree for the
Mafia not a de market Christmas gift by
the way
oh well done so um gotta give me
something I mean you got calamari number
one in your mouth Kraft DJ well I mean I
we had that we had that conversation he
kind of heard where I was where I was
hearing and I do my mock drafts not off
of necessarily what I would do but off
of what I expect to happen well I think
you can you can do that I can do that
math all right so then that'll be on
nfl.com later okay yeah nfl.com be on
the lookout come be on the lookout for
all of that coming out of the combine
what are the pro days that you're going
to give me that what's the Daniel
Jeremiah produce schedule so you could
sense yeah obviously what you think
about you saw first one is Oklahoma so
obviously doesn't get this isn't that a
chance see Tyler Murray it sounds like
he is gonna do everything so I know
Lamar Jackson did not run a 40 last year
to see Tyler Murray do that get out
there and throw it around a little bit
so that'll be a fun one
I'm gonna go Alabama and their whole
host oh hi Oh state I mean are they fast
by the way is a high Oh state they're
fast players may have fast tires man so
did Oklahoma so didn't miss it you know
I mean I mean a soda Ole Miss so did
Mississippi State I mean how did those
teams now begin guys you know but how
did those how do those teams not win in
the SEC this year I mean with all of
these kids coming to the next level I
know that there might be a naive
question to ask but it was that's all I
kept thinking throughout the broadcast
on weekend long yeah it was pretty it
was interesting when I think if you
could have combined the Mississippi
State defensive players with the old
most offensive players you have an all
Mississippi team okay so you're gonna go
from Oklahoma going to Clemson Jay told
a bow in the our three to look out for
him I don't think I don't think I'm on a
Clemson because all those guys worked
out let's go I'm gonna go see Duke with
you know see Daniel Jones
sory to see Trulock another one in there
those two first-round pictures thank the
grout I might go to Delaware because I'm
a seer ad really did not work out right
might get out there so you'll see the
old Blue Hens do you think both of those
quarterbacks you mentioned Dukes Jones
and Missouri's Locke our first rounders
this year well in the mock draft that I
sent in about four minutes ago I had
wanted it you in there okay
I'm not liking all the teams Pete in the
head I'm not liking it I'm not liking it
I'm not liking it cuz at some point you
know we're gonna find this stuff out I'm
trying to give the Rich Eisen shape
noise and listeners a little nugget here
I think I think one of them's a lock
okay
hey very very well done hey great job
this weekend it was great it really was
and thanks for timing the run that was
pretty neat to have you involved to meet
them to me the u.s. like was the
highlight of the week and I had a blast
up there such a fun time but there was
nothing better than hang out with Conor
down on the field and getting to visit
with him throughout that process what a
neat kid and what an awesome awesome
thing you've built here for st. Jude and
it was it was a pleasure just to be a
very very small part no you were a big
part of it well less because Connor Wray
the twelve-year-old from st. Jude his
hand time was much more rich eyes and
friendly than yours to be very honest I
think he was hoping for like a Rich
Eisen mug out of that no no I'm so glad
you got to meet him that was a fun time
and the fundraising was through the roof
I'm about to get to that so I appreciate
the time DJ all right travel safe or
your gravel safe travel safe throughout
the the pro day season
here's Daniel Jeremiah the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience